DOUG KRAFT: So I
invite you to imagine
a pretty human ancestor-- furry,
lemur-like creature living
furtively in the
primordial forest.
And so he's walking
through the forest.
And he sees
something attractive.
Maybe it's some food or a
potential sexual partner.
And there is this wired instinct
that draws all his attention
right down to that object,
whatever it is, and prepares
his body to move towards it.
And then he notices something
that's uncomfortable.
Maybe it's a large predator.
And the same instinct
draws all his attention
right down to that beast,
blots out everything else,
and prepares his body
to get out of there.
So this instinct gives him an
obvious evolutionary advantage.
To be effective, it
has to be very fast.
And to be fast, it
has to be simple.
And to be simple, it
doesn't figure out
what to do about the food,
or the mate, or the predator.
It just says, this is good.
Figure it out.
This is bad.
And you'll notice that
the instinct directs
all its attention out
there into the world
to whatever is going on
there, rather than inside
and how it feels about it.
And if you think
about it a little bit,
it makes lot of sense.
If he just got really
caught up-- oh, that lady.
She's hot.
I feel so lovely inside.
I feel light and joyful.
Oh, it's so wonderful.
He gets all caught
up in how he feels,
she's likely to move on
before his DNA gets a chance
to reproduce.
And if he gets all caught
up in oh that ugly beast.
I was having such a good day.
And now I just feel my
stomach's all tied in knots.
And I don't like to
have sweaty palms.
If he gets all tied up in how
it feels to be so frightened,
he and his DNA are much
more likely to get eaten.
So this instinct is the
opposite of introspection.
Puts all our attention out
there, rather than in here.
We humans have such an instinct.
I don't have scientific data
as to its evolutionary origins.
But it certainly behaves as if
these speculations are true.
It is fast.
It is simple.
It is pre-cognitive,
it's pre-verbal.
And it focuses
all our attention.
It just narrows our
attention down to one
object out there,
whatever that is.
We have lots and lots of
names for this instinct.
Desire.
Attraction.
Attachment.
Fixation.
Disliking.
Revulsion.
Disgust.
Fear.
Anger.
Uptightness.
It's the feeling that gives
rise to the thought I like it.
I don't like that.
I want more.
Get me out of here.
But the instinct
itself is pre-verbal.
I can't say this enough.
It is pre-verbal.
It is pre-cognitive, and
arises so quickly inside us
that we don't have
any control over it.
It just comes in uninvited.
So perhaps a better term
for it is getting hooked,
or even the devil made me do it.
In Tibet, the word for
it is shempa, or shempa.
If any of you are
familiar with any
of the writings of
Pema Chodron, you
may have come across this term.
But in the earliest Buddhist
text it is called tanha.
T-A-N-H-A. Tanha.
Tanha is the so-called second
of four ennobling truths
of the Buddha, which says that
our experience of difficulty--
not necessarily the
stimulus for it--
but the roots of our
experience of difficulty
inside is this instinctual type.
And the third
ennobling truth says
that we can release it
and relax regardless
of our circumstances.
I'm a bit of a
Buddhist geek, so I
could go into all kinds
of technical detail.
But what I would like
to do this afternoon
is come at this in
a little broader,
for a more practical
frame of reference.
I want to reflect with
you around this question--
how can we thrive
during difficult times?
It's not how do we survive.
How do we manage.
How do we get by.
How do we stumble through.
No.
It's how do we-- are there
ways that we can actually
thrive during difficult times?
Are there ways in which we
can navigate rough waters
and still have our lives
feel deep and enriched,
and our hearts feel open?
And I think the key to answering
that question is actually
tanha, this
instinctual tightening.
But the sense it focuses
all our attention
out there in the world,
it is surprisingly
elusive, surprisingly
difficult to see
in our everyday experience.
So I want to start today by
spending some time talking
about just how to recognize
it in our daily experience.
And then we'll
take a little time
at looking at what are some
of the things that trigger it,
and bring it forth in us.
And then that will
set the stage for us
to look at this-- the
more crucial question.
How do we release
it and relax so
that we can feel enriched
even in difficult times?
And as David mentioned, I
talk about this at more length
in my book "Buddha's Map."
So if you're interested in
it, you can pick that up.
How's that for very slyly
sneaking in a commercial?
So start with how
to recognize it.
I was trying to think of
a good analogy for what
it's like to recognize this
instinctual tightening.
And what came to me was my
boys when they were little,
searching for Easter eggs.
So on Easter Sunday
morning they would run out
in the yard looking
for Easter eggs.
They were hidden out there.
And they would look
inside little boxes
and behind trees and in holes.
And they just couldn't find any.
Because the Easter
Bunny-- my wife and I--
always hid the Easter
eggs in plain sight.
We'd take a yellow
one and put it
in a batch of yellow
flowers, and a green one
in a tuft of green grass,
and a bright red one
on the little fire
truck in the sandbox.
So they were placed so they were
easy to see, but in such a way
that they blended
in with the yard.
So in their excitement, my boys
would overlook the obvious.
And then after a few
minutes they got it.
And they would stop,
relax, and look around.
And they would see
them everywhere.
So this instinctual
tightening is like that.
It is in plain sight.
But since it diverts
our attention
out there rather than in
here, we overlook the obvious.
But if we just stop
and look carefully,
we begin to see it everywhere.
I was talking earlier
before some of you came in.
Had the experience-- well, I
did this actually this morning,
driving in from Sacramento.
I was going down, the
traffic was moving fine.
It was thick, but it was moving.
And some guy came
in on the on ramp.
And I don't know
what you learned,
but I learned they're
supposed to yield.
At least that's my little
righteous attitude inside.
Well, he had just
squeezed himself in
And without even
thinking about it,
I could feel my hands tightening
on the steering wheel.
That's tanha.
Or maybe you're in a gentle,
free-flowing conversation
with a colleague or a friend.
And then her eyes cloud
over and she looks away.
And you say, did I
say something wrong?
And she says, no.
Everything's fine.
I have to go.
So you just witnessed that
instinctual tightening,
completely unnamed.
But you saw it there.
Other examples.
You're talking on
your cell phone
as you're walking
down the sidewalk.
And you go to cross the street.
You're carrying on
the conversation.
But your eyes just look up and
down the street for a moment.
You don't even think about it.
That instinctual
tightening is just
directing you to look
for traffic danger.
Here's another place where you
can always recognize tanha.
Complaining.
Any time there is complaining.
When you find yourself
complaining about something,
just go ahead and finish
it out, because you
may enjoy it on some level.
But just sort of
watch and you'll see,
you'll feel the
places tightening up
in you a little bit.
I was on my way home, and
stopped into the grocery store.
We needed some-- every morning
I have a protein smoothie
with milk and bananas.
And we were out of all that.
So I needed some milk and
bananas and a few other things,
just about five or six things.
So I went in the grocery
store, put them in the basket.
And as I was heading
for the checkout line,
there must have been
five or six checkout
counters that were working.
And all of them were backed
up three or four carts,
except for one that was empty.
So I navigated towards it.
And as I did, I noticed a woman
coming from the other side
with this overflowing basket.
And she was headed for it too.
So my pace-- I didn't
even think about it-- just
picked up a little bit.
Oh, did I cut you off?
I'm sorry.
Oh no.
That's OK.
So that's a little bit of tanha.
Oh I was considering going
to bed early one night,
when my wife said
that she wanted
to check her emails on the
computer in the bedroom.
And so I said to her, OK.
I'll just stretch out in the
other room for a few moments.
And she said, oh no.
I don't want to drive you out.
I'll check it out
in the morning.
Sounds like a very civil
adult conversation.
But if you had
actually witnessed it,
you would have noticed that my
voice was just a little pouty.
Oh, I'll go sit
in the other room.
And her voice was
a little irritated.
Both of us had contracted a
little bit into that tanha.
I picked up a ream of paper off
the shelf in the office supply
store.
And rather than go
to the checkout line,
I just started wandering
down the aisles
a little bit to see if there
was something else, you know--
[INAUDIBLE].
Oh, pens.
No.
I've got enough pens.
Maybe-- oh, labels.
And then suddenly I
realized what I was doing.
There was this little place
that contracted just a little
that was looking for something
that would feel good to buy.
You ever done that?
So I recognized that little
bit of tightening inside me.
And when I did, I couldn't
help but smile and kind
of laugh at myself internally
and just head for the checkout
line.
The Dalai Lama was at a
conference in Los Angeles.
This a number of years ago.
And he was staying
at a hotel that
was 10 blocks from
the conference center.
So every morning and
every evening somebody
drove from back and
forth from his hotel
to the conference room.
And in that ten-block
stretch, there
were about five blocks that were
filled with electronics stores.
And I don't know if
you know anything
about the Dalai Lama,
particularly his early years.
But he's always been fascinated
with Western technology.
So in his opening remarks one
morning at this conference
center, he said, looking out
the car window this morning,
I wanted things without
even knowing what they were.
So if you worry
about having tanha,
just know you're
in good company.
The Dalai Lama has it too.
So this tightening, it feels
like a tug, or an urge,
or a drive.
It kind of pushes
us a little bit.
And it's uncomfortable.
It gets our attention
by creating attention,
and then pushing us to
do something about it.
And if there's nothing
we can do to resolve it,
then we're left with a
kind of an unnamed edginess
just begging for resolution.
You know that place?
Talking here before we started,
a lot of you feel that.
You're not quite
sure what it is.
It's just a kind of
accumulated edginess.
While this instinct
was obviously
very helpful in
primal situations,
and is still helpful today
in simple situations,
in the complexities and
nuances of modern life,
sometimes it really is
not terribly helpful,
because what it does is it gets
us to focus in on one detail.
It just goes whoosh.
When the resolution to a lot of
the issues we're dealing with
are really complex,
where you really
have to see the whole forest.
You have to have this
broad vision to see that.
I'm just assuming all of
you know what I talk about.
It's seeing people-- it's
hard to see in ourselves,
but you see other people
dealing with the situation.
And they just latch on
to some little detail.
And it's never going
to be solved that way.
Or if you want some real
live examples of all this,
just watch the
political campaigns.
I don't recommend it.
But you know,
they're always sort
of latching on some detail
and point to it for blame.
So this tanha, this
instinctual tightening,
to a greater or lesser degree,
I think colors almost all
of human experience to
some degree or another.
And when you get
too much of it--
If you have absolutely none,
then life gets kind of dull.
But when you get
too much, there's
just an edginess that you don't
know quite what to do with.
So let me shift
gears here and turn
from what it feels like to
look at some of the things that
trigger it in us.
Some of the triggers are really
obvious-- just large things.
Job stress.
Relationship difficulties.
Economic hardship.
Medical problems.
Our children's difficulties.
Economic insecurity.
War.
Political inanity.
Do any of you have ever
watch the campaign and think,
oh, this is so lovely to watch?
Grr.
So those are the
obvious triggers.
But there are very
subtle ones that
can set it off in us as well.
Loneliness.
You know, soft annoyances.
Quiet worries.
A sense of meaninglessness.
Why am I doing this now?
Purposelessness.
It can be very quiet
and hard to see.
But it creates that little
discomfort in there,
wanting something, or wanted
to be rid of something
we have can create it as well.
So let me just ask.
What are some of the sources
of stress or difficulty
in your life?
I just want to see
if we can create
a list of with a variety.
What is it that hooks
you or gets to you?
You don't have to explain it.
We'll just start calling.
Or maybe it's not for you.
Maybe it's a loved one.
You don't want to
identify yourself.
AUDIENCE: Relationships.
DOUG KRAFT: Relationships.
AUDIENCE:
Interpersonal conflict.
DOUG KRAFT:
AUDIENCE: Taxes.
DOUG KRAFT: Taxes.
AUDIENCE: Workload
and the work demand.
DOUG KRAFT: Workload
Release dates.
I remember I worked as a high
performance graphics programmer
back in the eighties
for a little while.
And the first release I was on--
you know, at the last minute,
it's like we're--
last week and a half,
it's like everybody is just
working like banshees trying
to get this thing out.
We finally got it out.
We're all going to go out
and have lunch together.
And this note came around from
our boss that said, great.
Good work.
Good product.
You did wonderful.
Go out, celebrate, and be
back in a half an hour,
because we're already
behind for the next one.
So other types of things
that trigger this.
What gets to you?
AUDIENCE: Selfishness.
DOUG KRAFT: Selfishness.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wondering
if I'm doing what
I'm doing for the right reasons,
or out of fear of other people.
DOUG KRAFT: Right.
Right.
Sometimes you can be inspired
to do something and be
afraid about not doing
it at the same time.
At least I can.
Other things.
AUDIENCE: Misunderstandings.
DOUG KRAFT: Misunderstandings.
They happen all the time.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Feeling rushed.
DOUG KRAFT: Feeling rushed.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's nice to just
sort of take your time.
And somebody is pushing.
And you can be doing
the same thing.
And doing it one way is fun.
When it's rushed,
it becomes no fun.
It's almost like
you feel cheated.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Emotional isolation.
DOUG KRAFT: Emotional isolation.
That's a huge one.
Yeah.
OK.
You've got the idea.
So the question is, the question
is, what do we do about these?
What we do about them?
Now remember, this tightening
focus all our attention out
there.
That's what the instinct is.
And sometimes that makes sense.
I mean, I assume
that all of us here
have some commitment to
living life out in the world.
Anybody here live in a convent,
or monastery, you know?
So we embrace the
interdependent web.
And so oftentimes
to solve problems,
we like to just deal with
them on their own terms.
So you get sick or have an
injury, have a concussion.
What do you do?
Rather than just
pray or meditate,
you go to a doctor or a
health care professional,
or look at diet or rest
or exercise, or something
to work with the body
on its own terms.
Or if your job is in
trouble, what do you do?
Well, talk to the boss
or refresh your resume.
Or look towards getting
some more education,
increasing your job
skills, networking,
dealing with the job
somehow on its own terms.
Or relationship difficulties.
What's the first advice
we usually give somebody?
Like, have you
talked to the person?
Have you actually
talked to them?
And if it's difficult
to talk to them,
maybe talk to a counselor or a
good friend or a support group,
or something that deals with
relationships on its own terms.
Or just a very simple thing.
You want something.
You have enough money.
What do you do?
You go out and buy it.
So if these strategies resolve
the problem, that's great.
That's great.
Cure the disease.
Find a new job.
Resolve our kids
of streperousness.
Buy that piece of music.
And that's great.
But there are some times
when we do everything we can.
And the problem just lingers.
I moved to Sacramento
in the summer of 2000.
I was living on the East Coast.
And I was called to come
out to serve a large church,
a large progressive church.
And at that time,
our youngest son
was just about to go into his
senior year of high school
in this charter school
in Massachusetts
that he had helped found
and poured his heart into.
So the first year
I came out alone.
And he and my wife stayed
back in Massachusetts
so he could finish up his high
school year in this community
that he knew.
And mostly it was OK.
You know, I missed them.
But I was busy getting
to know a new community.
There was a lot
for me to do there.
And I knew the separation
was going to be temporary.
But I have to tell you,
Friday evenings were hard.
Fridays had been family time.
Used to play board games
or go to a movie or just
hang out together.
And so you know,
Friday afternoon,
as the twilight
began to settle in,
I could feel this sort of aching
in the center of my chest.
So I would call them and
talk to them on the phone.
But it wasn't, that
wasn't quite the same.
Sometimes the
pangs of loneliness
felt just intolerable.
Sometimes there is no
cure for the disease.
Sometimes there are no
appropriate jobs for us.
Sometimes, most of
the time, we really
don't have a power to
solve the political scene.
Sometimes-- well,
not sometimes-- the
loved one who died.
They're just not coming back.
Sometimes our kids have
difficulties that just
don't have an easy solution.
They just don't.
These are the truly
difficult times.
Sometimes the stress
that we're feeling,
we do everything that we know.
And it's just not enough.
What do we do then?
What we do then?
There are three
popular strategies
for dealing with
unsolvable problems.
Grab something.
Push something away.
Space out.
The Buddha talked about them.
They are current with us.
I think they've been
all in between years.
They will be around for
hundreds of more years.
Grab something.
Push away.
Or space out.
So let's talk a little bit
about each of those strategies.
So the first strategy is
to just grab for something.
Or maybe we become kind of
needy, feel a little needy.
So this unresolved
tightening oftentimes
does feel like a hunger, or
a thirst, or an emptiness.
And so we look for something
to fill that vacuum,
that space inside.
I remember, it was the beginning
of my senior year of college.
And I broke up
with a girlfriend.
And it was the
right thing to do.
And I knew it had to be done.
But I was really upset about it.
And I just don't know
what to do with myself.
So I went out and I
bought a record album.
Anybody remember those?
Anyway, what I actually bought
was Simon and Garfunkel's
"Bridge Over Troubled Waters."
And it was soothing.
Many people get in
the habits of shopping
as a way of trying
to feel better.
Or rather than get
stuff, some of us--
I'm more inclined
this other way--
is to actually
collect experiences
that will distract us.
There's a variation on
this strategy that I'm
sure all of us have seen,
which is rather than do stuff
ourselves, we try to get other
people to do things for us.
Many people try
to control others
as a way of handling
their own discomfort.
None of you do that, I'm sure.
We've all seen people
become controlling.
And sometimes these strategies
are actually soothing and help
us relax a little bit.
But if they don't
address the true hunger,
they're not going to have any
really lasting or sustaining
value.
So grabbing something
is the first strategy.
If that doesn't work,
sometimes what we do
is we try to do the opposite.
Rather than grasping
things, we push things away.
We become irritable or angry.
We've all seen this in others.
We've all felt it in ourselves.
We snap at people more readily.
We become less tolerant
of their foibles.
We lose our temper,
criticize more readily.
Things that used to
roll off our back
now kind of get under our skin.
So expressing that irritation
can help feel a little better.
But again, if it doesn't
deal with the real problem,
it's not a lasting solution.
You could be mad
at people at work
and come home and kick the
dog until the dog dies.
But unless you deal with
whatever [INAUDIBLE],
it just doesn't work.
So the third strategy
then is to space out.
There is nothing I can do.
So I'm just not going
to think about it.
Always stay busy, or
medicate ourselves
with alcohol or something else.
Or just don't pay attention
to how lousy you feel inside.
We just numb out.
All of us have done this.
And it can be helpful
sometimes for a short term,
for a temporary situation.
But as a long-term strategy
for a long-term difficulty,
it is disastrous.
Makes us all vulnerable
to addictions.
I have done a lot of things.
I worked as a psychotherapist
for about a dozen years.
And the clients that
came to me were all
using one of these
strategies, or sometimes
a combination of them.
So my job was to
listen carefully
and attentively to what
was going on with them so
that together we might
find more effective ways
that they could
enrich their lives.
And when I listened
carefully to their stories,
it frankly didn't surprise me
that they felt so messed up.
What astounded me was
that they weren't all
locked up on the back ward
of psychiatric hospital.
If we listen deeply
to what many of us
have gone through as
children or adults,
it's amazing that we're
as healthy as we are.
I mean, truly.
Truly.
The human spirit is
incredibly resilient.
It's amazing the depth
of pain and suffering
that we can experience
and still come out
the other side with
hearts and minds
that are open and
supple and alive.
Yeah.
We may feel the pain of it.
But it's amazing what we can go
through without being crippled.
But there's one
thing that brings us
down faster than anything else.
There's one thing that causes
us to crash and burn more
quickly than anything else.
Isolation.
When we're not alone,
our natural wisdom
and compassion and
empathy can flow even
during very, very
difficult times.
And there's one person
whose good attention
we need more than anyone else.
It's the person we spend the
most time with night and day.
Ourselves.
So if we're busy
grasping at things,
or being irritated
with other people,
pushing things away,
or spacing out,
we're not truly
present with ourselves.
We have abandoned our hurt.
For have abandoned our grief.
We have abandoned our
loneliness, our fear.
We have abandoned ourselves.
So if we want to thrive
during difficult times,
it is crucial that we learn
to be present to ourselves
more and more and more.
I remember one Friday,
my little apartment,
I had to talked to Eric and
Dana, my wife and my son,
on the phone.
And I thought about
going to a movie.
But somehow that night
it just seemed empty.
It just seemed vacuous.
I could've called some
people in Sacramento.
But that wasn't
the same as family.
So I put some music
on, which both soothed
and stimulated my loneliness.
And then I found
myself just pacing
around my little apartment.
From the living room to
the bedroom to the kitchen
back to the living room.
Just pacing faster and faster,
feeling more and more frantic,
knowing there was
nothing I could
do to assuage this aching
that I was feeling.
There was nowhere to run.
And then I finally got it.
There was no where I could run.
So I just stopped.
I remember standing
still right there
in the middle of my living
room, my little living room.
And I realized that
at that very moment,
just as in this
moment right now,
there are millions of people
around the planet feeling just
as lonely as I was, maybe more.
There are hundreds of millions
of people right now grieving
the loss of a loved one.
There are countless
people who are worried
about their children,
concerned about how they're
gonna make ends meet,
frightened by disease,
cowering before violence.
And most of them weren't
doing anything wrong.
Things just don't work out
in this life sometimes.
Everything we love is going to
be taken from us at some point.
We all die.
Our society does us an
incredible disservice
by reassuring us that we
are captains of our ship.
We are directors of our fate.
We are in charge of our future.
That's bonkers.
We have some influence.
Yeah, we can influence things.
But bad things happen to
good people all the time.
So standing there in my living
room, I thought, oh, yeah.
That's right.
That's just how
life is sometimes.
Everything breaks.
Sometimes things just-- I'm
not bad for feeling bad.
Stuff happens.
So I stopped running.
And I sat down in a chair in
the living room to just feel it.
I couldn't run from it.
I just sat down to feel
it, just be present.
I wasn't trying to talk myself
into or out of anything.
Just trying to be present.
And you know what?
It didn't feel very good.
It felt pretty awful.
But at least I had myself.
At least I had one person in the
room, one friend in the room--
me.
And with that, the loneliness--
how can I say this?
It began to soften.
It didn't go away.
But since I wasn't fighting
against it anymore,
it was like it began to
spread out and soften.
And I began to feel poignant
and moist and alive, rather
than dry, dusty, and barren.
If we want to thrive
during difficult times,
it is so important to recognize
this instinctual response
on its own terms.
It's not a thought.
It's not an idea.
It's not a religious creed.
It's not a
metaphysical principle.
It's not a philosophical axiom.
It's none of that.
It's a wired-in, pre-vebal,
pre-conceptual biological
reflex.
A mental, emotional, and
sometimes physical tightening.
And it focuses all our faculties
out there into the world,
rather than in here.
The instinct is
very, very simple.
And I mean that simple
both in the sense
that it's not very complicated.
And it's also simple in the
sense that it's kind of stupid.
If there's nothing that we can
do to resolve the situation,
it doesn't know how to let go.
We can lie awake at night in
this endless loop of thoughts
about our health, our
relationship, our situation.
Go around and around and around.
Anybody here ever done that?
Anybody here not done that?
It goes round and round.
And you just don't know
how to let go of it.
It just doesn't know
how to let go of itself.
In these cases I think
it's so important
to shift our attention
from the story line,
from the ideas, from
what the situation is,
to just notice just in
the simplest terms, what's
going on inside, just to see
the inner holding directly.
Because this is magical.
Because when we see it
fully, it tends to soften.
And if it doesn't do that,
we can invite it to soften.
You just be with
it, the same way
you would be with a child who
wakes up from a nightmare.
What do you do?
You don't sit there.
You don't try to talk
the kid out of it.
They had the experience.
You're just present
in a heartful way.
And as we do that,
some of the swirl
and the thoughts and the
emotions start to wind down.
It's very, very simple.
But it's very difficult
to do, because it
goes against this evolutionary
reflex to look out there.
So when you do it
with yourself, it's
very important to be kind
and gentle and patient,
to just be there.
But as we relax
that inner tautness,
we don't start
thriving overnight.
But without the tension, the
spinning begins to slow down.
It's the tension
that drives all that.
If you can just release it.
Forget about the stories,
just release the tension.
And they start to
run out of gas.
And they slow down a little.
And with this,
there is something
deeply mysterious and deeply
human that begins to emerge.
We begin to notice a poignant
well-being that has nothing
to do with fixing anything.
We begin to touch, or get just
a sense of a wholeness that
doesn't depend on us
controlling anything.
Some people would call this
well-being God, or the divine,
or spirit.
Other people would call it
human essence, or Buddha nature.
I don't care what you call it.
I really don't, because
it's not an idea.
It is a-- it's just
this wired-in reflex.
It's pre-verbal.
All we have to do is just
notice this elusive holding
on its own terms.
And it starts to soften.
And this doesn't make us
transcend the world out
into some other realms.
But what it does
do is it gives us
some of the courage,
the patience, the heart,
and the intelligence that come
more fully back into this life.
And to do what we
can for ourselves
and for our fellow creatures.
And as we do that,
our sense of self
begins to expand and
soften a little bit.
And we think, you
know, maybe I'm
not this shrunken peach pit of
a self that I thought I was.
And the whole sense
of self begins
to expand out a little bit.
And with this we
are truly on a path
towards striving, even in the
most difficult of situations.
So before I open up for
questions and comments,
can we just spend a few
moments in silence together?
I want to invite you to close
your eyes or let your eyes rest
someplace undistracting.
And let your awareness
drift inward.
Just see if there is any
tightness or tension in there,
tension in your body,
edginess in your emotions,
holding in your mind.
Just see.
No judgments.
And if you notice any tension,
don't try to change anything.
If your thoughts are rambling
or your attention is wandering,
let them ramble and wander.
Just notice any tightness
and invite it to soften.
And if there's no
tension, that's great.
Just notice the peace,
well-being, and spaciousness.
And let it radiate
naturally from you.
Let's let it flow out.
Just notice the
flux inside, too,
how things will rise,
and then softly pass.
Just let it be what it
is, relaxing tension.
And sending out well-being to
your fellow human creatures
around you, and all creatures.
out there in the world.
Thank you.
I welcome comments, questions.
If you'd just rather stay
with the inner space,
that's fine, too.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: Is there a mic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Sure.
So you talked about
the quality of anxiety
without fixation on external
thing to explain it.
DOUG KRAFT: Without?
AUDIENCE: Without the
fixation or the obsession
with something external to
explain it, which I think
is a really interesting idea.
I'm curious what
your thoughts are on
whether that's just-- is
that just an innate part
of being a human being?
Or is that-- because
like psychotherapy,
for example, or
psychoanalysis, would
suggest that there
is some underlying
cause for that anxiety.
Whereas other methods
of thought seem
to explain it as just
sort of an innate element
of the human experience.
So I'm wondering what your
interpretation of that is.
DOUG KRAFT: Yeah.
The Eastern and Western
models of where that come from
are a little bit different.
And I think there's some
value in all of them.
I don't think the tension
is innate to our essence,
but that we all
collect it from places.
Little difference between the
Eastern and Western psychology
is that the Western
psychology looks
more for the causes and history,
et cetera, that trigger it.
The Eastern psychology--
and I include
the meditative
disciplines in this--
they're more interested in the
quality of the mind that is
looking at whatever's going on.
So just to give
you a simple model.
Here is like clear, relaxed--
I call it pure awareness.
Awareness that doesn't
have any agenda.
Here is what you
see in the world.
And that awareness looks through
all the attitudes in the mind.
So if you are uptight or
anxious about something,
it can color your
perception of everything.
And so what you
are uptight about
may not be what you
think you're seeing.
And so what I'm
actually suggesting
is that where we get
the most mileage is
by looking at the qualities
that are in the mind heart,
regardless of where
they came from.
Because as those can
relax a little bit,
we can actually see more
clearly what's going on.
If there's a lot of
anger, a lot of fear,
a lot of depression
or something,
that colors everything
that we experience.
And they get all caught
up in the stories.
And yeah, they
probably do have causes
and et cetera, if
we had brains that
were 17 times the
size of ours, we
might be able to
figure all that out.
But in terms of
just practically,
of how you live day
to day, being aware
of the quality of a mind.
So example, as you're sitting
here, you can feel this.
Does your awareness feel light?
Does it feel sleepy?
Does it feel tense?
Does it feel excited?
It's just actually being aware
of the quality of the mind
so that you bring-- it's
a tricky language here.
Tradition is called wholesome
qualities, awareness, patience,
kindness, compassion, joy,
peacefulness are qualities
of mind that have very
little tension in them,
or lead in the direction
of less tension.
And so as you bring
more of those,
as you just invite
more of those in,
then you see more
clearly what's going on.
And if there's some insights
into a particular situation
that you need, they will just
show up all by themselves.
But if we become
Sherlock Holmes,
go in and try to
figure things out,
when we're trying to
we are working from
our assumptions
about-- working from what
we already understand.
Ouspensky wrote-- he said
the chief difficulty he found
was that most people keep
translating what they hear
into their habitual language so
that they cease to think they
can ever hear anything new.
And so as you relax all
that and see things fresh,
there are fresh
insights that come up.
Does that make sense?
Am I making it too esoteric?
So what you decide to do about
something has a lot of effect
just on that particular
moment how you
look at it, how you hold it.
Whether you bring patience and
kindness and openness to it,
or anger and judgment, has
a big effect down the road,
has a big effect down the road.
So this is really in
it for the long run.
So it's a lot of difficulties
recurring in your life.
Greed wants to solve
and fix it right now.
And as you go for that, you
just add more tension to it.
But if you actually
sit back and say, wow.
I haven't been this
depressed in a long time.
Far out.
You know, it's like just get a
little bit of space around it,
bring a little kindness
and patience to it,
that actually opens the
mind and heart out more,
so it can see more clearly.
When it can see more
clearly, we become wiser.
When we have lot of
tension, we get stupider.
So it's just a way--
wisdom is perception.
That's all it is.
Cleverness is
figuring things out.
But the wise person
is one that can just
see into the heart
of the situation,
or see to the heart of a person.
So we're actually trying
to cultivate wisdom
by allowing the mind to
be softer and more open.
Thank you.
That's a great question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you
provide some tips
on how to break out of
those habits we often
get stuck in using
things like for me
I think it's just keeping
myself incessantly busy,
whether it's in work
or personal life.
And I think partly that's
maybe avoiding or not
figuring out how to deal with
what it is that's going on.
And even when I
try and meditate,
it's fighting the
noise in my head
and not being able to
quite break past it.
I'm sure there's no
easy solution to it.
But any new insights or
thoughts would be appreciated
on how to make the change.
DOUG KRAFT: There are lots
and lots of techniques.
But let me just say a
couple general things is
that in meditation-- this
is the mistake people make.
In meditation our job
is not to fix anything.
It's not to get rid of anything.
Here is an esoteric
secret that ought
to be obvious to everyone.
If you have an
unwholesome quality,
let's say anger, or
aversion, or fear.
And you have wholesome
qualities like peace, awareness,
mindfulness, in the mind at
the same time, which one wins?
The wholesome always wins.
We get very cynical about it.
But you can feel it.
So if you're feeling
some tension,
and then if you can just step
back and see it clearly, oh.
Look at that tension.
It has a subtle tendency
to relax a little bit.
So what that means when you
meditate is rather than trying
to get rid of all those
rambling thoughts,
is to just let them run.
But just relax any tension
that you feel within them.
And then what happens
is those thoughts
will gradually run out of gas.
It's the tension
that fuels them.
If you relax around it, and
it's got a full tank of gas,
it'll keep going for a while.
But you're not putting
more gas in the tank.
So it will gradually run out.
If you try to stop,
then it's like me,
as I was talking before
about my cat Bailey.
When it was hissing.
You know, it's like slapping it.
That's not going
to calm him at all.
But if I scratch him
and I get him purring,
[INAUDIBLE] it's OK.
Then it opens up.
So I think it's really
important to bring
a lot of heart, a
lot of patience,
and to cut ourselves
a lot of slack.
My little organization-- I had
to put together a nonprofit
because people were
giving me money that I
was giving to other people.
So I needed to keep
it all transparent.
And so but I call Easing Awake.
Easing Awake.
That the key to
awakening is actually
cultivating a certain
amount of ease,
because when the mind is
relaxed, it is very sensitive.
There's a little flicker
over there, you see it.
You know, when you're like this,
[GROWLS] then a train runs over
and you hardly notice it.
The difficulty with
this in the beginning
is that there's
no reason for you
to trust that this is
actually going to work.
I mean, you can
take my word for it.
But that's just my--
I mean, who am I?
But you have to try it enough.
And then as you begin
to feel it working,
then actually it's faith,
confidence builds up.
OK.
That the peace and
well-being we're looking for
is actually here all the time.
I'll give you my
little image of it.
You have a classroom
filled with kids.
And they're throwing
knives and books,
and yelling, and playing boom
boxes and all that stuff.
And over there in
the corner, there's
a kid who's writing poetry.
And you wouldn't know it
because of all the hubbub.
But then you come
in class very early.
And the kid is the
only one there.
And so you go over and
you sit down next to her.
Maybe you talk a little bit.
Or maybe you just
kind of sit together.
And then as the other kids
come in, they rattle the chairs
and create all this noise,
and all that stuff is there.
So everything comes back.
But now you know what
that's like over there.
And even in the hubbub, you can
actually feel that over there.
And that's when you start
the little confidence.
And then rather than
fight all the hubbub,
you just sort of relax
into that peaceful place,
and then allow whatever
insights come out of that.
So that's a quick answer.
AUDIENCE: So in order to
maintain the relaxed mind
in your day-to-day
life, like for example,
like when you're in the grocery
store or something like that,
how do you respond to
tension you come across?
DOUG KRAFT: The most
important thing is to see it.
To take the broader
frame of your question,
I think it's really
helpful to have some type
of spiritual practice.
So I meditate every morning.
And part of that is, quite
frankly, what it is, is it's
putting myself in a
quiet room without any
of those other
distractions, where
it's just easier to actually
feel the kid writing poetry.
So I become more
familiar with that.
And then as that
gets stronger, it
begins to carry
out into the world.
We also have a process
that's the most effective one
I've ever found that we
affectionately call the Six Rs.
Is when you get distracted
or something pulls you away,
you recognize what it is.
OK.
I'm pulled away.
The mind is jumping,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then you release it.
And release it just means
you let it be what it is.
Suzuki Roshi-- the Zen
teacher-- said the best way
to control a cow was to put
it in a very large pasture.
So you just give it a lot of
space, recognize, release,
then you relax any
tension that you feel.
And as that tension
goes out, there'll
be a little bit of
space in the mind,
and all the old habits will
actually pour back into that.
So it's recognize,
release, relax.
And then you want to bring some
uplifted qualities in there.
And the easiest way
to do this is just
smile, just a little bit.
Like if you do it now you
can feel what happens.
What we know from the
way the brain operates
is when you smile a little bit,
it tends to lighten things.
Recognize, release,
relax, smile.
And then you go back to engage.
And so the people that are doing
meditation training with me,
they just got a lot of
experience with that.
And so what happens is that
becomes a wired-in habit.
So that when something
comes up, rather than just
go strangle, oh.
OK.
There it is.
Let it be.
And so you just kind of
get a foot in the door.
I am a great believer
in developing
some spiritual practice.
It's sort of like
going to a gym.
You know, you work out,
you strengthen muscles.
And the point is not to
become good at doing push ups,
but the point is to
strengthen your body,
you get a stronger body.
It's the same thing
with meditation practice
is to give yourself a break.
Set up some time periods
in which you can actually
practice that a little bit.
And even if it's nothing
else than just sitting
for a few minutes, that's
sort of what I did at the end,
is that little meditate.
Just knows what comes up,
the most important thing
is the relaxing the tension.
And so you get some
practice with that.
It's unreasonable to
expect that you'll
be able to do something that's
subtle in the midst of a crisis
at work.
But as you practice more, it
doesn't become a little bit
habitual.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So what do you do when
you're caught up already?
So you're already in
deep tension or stress.
DOUG KRAFT: OK.
That's a great question.
So one thing you
can do is work real
hard to get rid of the tension.
And that will just increase it.
Right?
So our job actually is
not to solve the tension.
Just imagine that maybe
it's not actually a problem,
that if you can cultivate
some wholesome qualities.
So awareness is a very, very
wholesome, very powerful thing.
So if you can just
be a little more
aware that things
are really tense,
that will tend to drain it out.
The difficulty is that
there's this in-between stage.
Some people call it the
dark night of the soul.
I call them Alfred
Hitchcock moments.
Where there is enough
awareness that when you're
caught up and angry
at somebody, and when
you want to throttle them,
you have enough clarity,
have enough awareness
inside, that says wow.
You know, I just
really-- I lost it here.
But the awareness is
not quite strong enough
to know what to do about it.
So that's the point when
you try to clamp down on it.
But actually frankly to
grab for peacefulness
is just a form of
greed or aversion.
Maybe it's aversion.
We get rid of something.
And so that doesn't help.
But what you want
to do is to create--
is to bring in more of
those wholesome qualities.
And I would say those six
Rs is a really effective way
to do that, because
it's kind of mechanical,
so that you just start bringing
a little more awareness.
Just knowing that particularly
if it's a deep pattern,
it's not going to
disappear overnight.
But you can get a
toe in the door.
And then after you've been
able to do it a few times,
then you get a little
bit of confidence.
Then maybe, maybe,
maybe this will work.
Maybe this will work.
So as your walking out of
here, and you think, oh.
I wish I'd asked that.
This is your chance.
AUDIENCE: Is everything
OK at some level?
DOUG KRAFT: On some level, I
mean, that's a great question.
It's actually a
pretty profound one.
OK.
Let me throw a curve at you.
But that's a great question.
So imagine this.
Every day in your life you walk
into a room, take your clothes
off, they take a picture of
you in a certain posture.
You live 100 years.
Now you take all those
frames and put them together
into a movie that runs
from, say, 15 minutes.
OK.
And then just to
make it more fun,
we start the movie a year before
you were born, and run it say,
five years after your death.
So I'm watching this film.
And so at first
there is nothing.
And then there is your mother.
She starts to swell up.
Pop out you come.
When you're nursing and peeing
and pooping, and not doing
too much.
You go through all that stuff.
But your body, you
know, it starts
to stretch out a little bit.
Maybe a little baby fat.
It goes down a little bit.
And there you are standing up.
And maybe five
minutes into the film
you know, you're coming
into adolescence.
And there's that
sort of vitality
of youth and young adults.
And the body gets stronger.
And then there's
a sort of plateau.
And the body sort of
droops a little bit.
And maybe the eyes are
sparkly, but the skin
is a little blotchy and the hair
starts to gray a little bit,
and it stoops a little bit more.
And then some of the light
goes out of the eyes.
And then there's this-- and then
13, 14 minutes into the film,
there's just this
body on the floor.
And the film goes on.
And so the skin
dries up, disappears.
It's gone.
There's just a skeleton.
And then gradually it starts
to crumble, turn to dust,
and blows away, and it's gone.
So where are you in all of this?
So it begins-- I know
it's a little esoteric.
But if you can
just picture that.
At any moment in time,
you're obviously here.
You're holding a microphone.
And you know, I'm here.
We're talking, et
cetera, et cetera.
But on this larger
spans of time.
So Buddhism is
famous for what they
say is that there is
nothing essential in us
that separates us
from everything else.
We are just a process.
And what happens-- and
this is evolutionary too--
is we latch onto and identify
with what I feel right now.
And if our happiness, if
the source of well-being
is keeping you just like
you are right now forever,
you're cooked.
It won't happen.
I remember the first time that
a close friend of mine died.
I was a sophomore or
junior year in high school.
And Larry was killed
in a car accident.
And that was pretty weird, just
to actually be with all that.
The strangest thing about it
all was that the next week we
had our French midterm
exam right on schedule.
And I remember sitting in
that French midterm taking
this, because Larry used
to sit up [INAUDIBLE].
I say, does anybody notice?
Larry is gone.
What are we doing?
You know, it's like. [GROWL].
I wanted to write on the
exam, [SPEAKING FRENCH].
It's like, does anybody
notice the guy is gone?
And I got it.
You know, that when
I die, there will
be a handful of people that
will mourn me for a few years.
But even they will get
up the next morning
and complain about politics
and everything else,
that life will go on without me.
And so a lot of the base tension
that we have is trying to hold
on to a kind of an eternal
existence that just isn't-- it
just isn't there.
And so if you can imagine
sort of really getting
that, that in not too many
years I'm going to be gone.
And hundred years
from now I don't
know if there will be any
sign I was ever on the planet.
And you can feel how hard
it is to hold that thought.
But if you can be with
that a little bit,
it's like something relaxes.
It's like, OK.
You know, we're just part
of an ongoing process.
And it's really OK.
And as you can tap
into that a little bit,
there really is a deep
kind of well-being
that is behind all of it.
It's not mine.
It's not yours.
But we're just there with it.
But we want to hold
onto our job, our body,
anything like that.
It's a disaster.
I remember-- oh, God.
First time I learned
where babies came from,
I was probably about--
I don't know-- five when
my mother told me the story.
You know, the sperm, and
the egg, and the sex act.
The whole thing.
And I think I had a pretty
typical five-year-old response
to it.
It was like, oh, you're kidding.
That's gross.
But I remember that night, lying
in bed looking at the ceiling
and thinking, so what if my
mother and father had not
gone to the University of
Michigan at the same time?
What if they had not
ever fallen in love?
What if they hadn't
been in the mood
to start a baby at a
particular afternoon in 1947,
or whenever it was?
What if a different one
of those five million
sperm, whatever it
is, hit the egg?
I could just think of
a zillion contingencies
in which I would not exist.
And nobody would notice.
The wouldn't even miss me.
They'd probably have
another second child
and give him my name.
You know, that our existence
here is such a fluke.
And if we really get that,
it's actually-- at first
it's kind of scary.
But we really get it, it's
actually quite joyful,
you know?
Cause every moment's a gift.
And that can be wonderful.
And the next moment, I go
back to the prehistoric scene.
walking through the jungle.
There is one guy who is
at one with everything.
The trees.
The lakes.
The saber tooth kitties.
The big bears.
It's all lovely.
And there's another guy who
is frightened of everything.
A little rustle,
and he runs around
like a paranoid squirrel.
Guess whose DNA we got?
I look at the squirrels
running out there.
You know, it's like whoa!
They are like so uptight.
But if they relax
a little bit, they
get eaten by the next
dog that came along.
So that's been bred into us.
But it's not metaphysical.
You know, it's not
how reality is.
It's just an artifact of
evolutionary processes.
Wow.
I didn't expect to [INAUDIBLE].
Anything more?
Or have you had enough?
So let me close with my
favorite poem of all time.
It kind of touches
on some of the things
you've been talking about, which
is peacefulness, equanimity,
and where you find it.
This poem about equanimity.
It was written by
Donald C. Babcock.
"Now we're ready to look at
something pretty special.
It is a duck, riding the ocean
100 feet beyond the surf.
No, it isn't a gull.
A gull always has a
raucous touch about him.
This is some sort of duck.
And he cuddles in the swell.
He isn't cold.
And he is thinking things over.
There's a big heaving
in the Atlantic.
And he is a part of it.
He looks a bit like a Mandarin
with a Lord Buddha meditating
under the Bodhi tree.
But he has hardly enough about
the eyes to be a philosopher.
He has poise, however, which
is what philosophers must have.
He can rest while the
Atlantic heaves because he
rests in the Atlantic.
Probably he doesn't know
how large the ocean is.
And neither do you.
But he realizes it.
And what does he do, I ask you.
He sits down in it.
He reposes in the immediate
as if it were infinity,
which it is.
That is religion.
And the duck has it.
He has made himself
part of the boundless
by easing himself into it
just where it touches him.
I like the little duck.
He doesn't know much.
But he has religion."
So thank you all for coming.
And thank you for your questions
and your good attention.
And may we all learn how
to sit down in the waves.
As far back as we can see into
history there have been waves.
They will always be there.
The art is learning how to sit
down in them, to rest in them.
That's where the true
peace comes from.
Namaste.
[APPLAUSE]